the honking of horns and flashing lights
have become warning signals for
Venezuelan immigrants trying to cross
the border from Venezuela into Brazil
the Brazilian Army are traitors out with
all these immigrants it was this
sentiment at a demonstration by
residents of the Brazilian border town
of parikamma that took South America's
immigration crisis to a new level on the
18th of August locals attacked
Venezuelan immigrants who'd been camping
in the town armed with sticks and stones
they expelled some 1,200 Venezuelans and
burned their belongings I'm working
Brazil I have four children in Venezuela
how am I going to send them food now the
residents deny that they're hunting the
Venezuelans down but insist they will
not allow the immigrants to stay in the
town after the attack we made an
agreement with the police to not let
them gather in crowds as soon as groups
of five or six people are seen together
we call the police the situation is
tense here not just for us but for them
as well they're not trustworthy people
the attack was the culmination of a
growing humanitarian crisis that's been
going on for more than a year a lack of
food and medical supplies together with
utility shortages have led to a mass
exodus from Venezuela since 2017 some
127 thousand Venezuelans have crossed
the Brazilian border into pocket i'ma
even though a majority of the migrants
have already left a number have stayed
and the small town is overcrowded with
little support from the federal
government and few resources tensions as
well as crime are on the increase
they came into my house and stole all of
my money some of it was a loan from a
friend and now I can't pay him back I am
for Venezuelans who want to stay here
and work but criminals must go to jail
it was the attack on Raimundo nanatsu
that unleashed that Saturday's fury and
fed a wave of xenophobia in the town as
a result the number of Venezuelans
crossing daily into Parker Aimie fell by
50% the following week desperation still
drives Venezuelans to cross the border
but they now spend the night in
improvised shelters at a truck parking
lot on the Venezuelan side entire family
sleep here they hope the next day will
bring a new life on the Brazilian side
some of their dreams are very simple
ones like just having enough food to eat
what do you eat in Venezuela nothing
there's nothing there and what would you
like to eat chocolate how long haven't
you eaten meat
it's been years not since Venezuela was
a rich country with no change in sight
it'll be some time longer before
Venezuela can end its current
humanitarian and economic crisis and
stem the exodus of Venezuelans looking
for a better life